cuando se hablan de terrorismo jihadista
Qué es lo primero que se os viene a la
cabeza seguramente cosas como el
atentado del 11s el ataque de la sala
batac clan en París el Isis luchando
salvajemente en Siria o Irak o el
atentado del 11m en España es decir que
por lo general situamos al yihadismo en
Oriente medio África y sobre todo Europa
Pero y si os dijera que ya va siendo
hora de poner a Sudamérica en este mapa
y si os dijera que hay un país
latinoamericano donde el yihadismo ya
tiene una presencia muy pero que muy
fuerte pues fijaos yihadistas del Caribe
Por qué Trinidad y Tobago se ha
convertido en capital del daes en
occidente Jesucristo está personificado
como un hombre blanco de ojos azules y
la gente odia la supremacía blanca dice
un imán bajo anonimato ni Argentina ni
Colombia ni México el país que muchos
analistas califican como el mayor nido
de jihadistas en todo occidente es
Trinidad ti Tobago este país es una
nación formada por dos Islas principales
a las costas de Venezuela
tradicionalmente Trinidad tiago ha
destacado por ser un gran exportador de
petróleo y gas natural pero pero a día
de hoy está en el punto de mira de la
inteligencia antiterrorista
internacional el yihadismo y la
violencia se han apoderado de su
territorio y tanto es así que Trinidad y
Tobago tiene la segunda mayor tasa de
omicidios del continente americano una
barbaridad Así que amigos las preguntas
están claras Cómo Diantre se ha
convertido Trinidad y Tobago en un
epicentro occidental del yihadismo Qué
implicaciones tendrá de Cara a la
seguridad global se avecina acaso una
nueva oleada terrorista en occidente
pues hoy en visal politic os lo contamos
todo
atentos
El génesis
[Música]
jihadista como muchos ya os imaginaréis
Trinidad cit bago no fue una excepción
para los imperios coloniales europeos
También estuvo Bajo su control desde
1592 con los primeros asentamientos
españoles ambas Islas pasaron luego por
manos francesas y terminaron finalmente
bajo el control británico de hecho
llegaron a convertirse en una
importantísima colonia productora de
algodón y azúcar y así fue hasta que
casi 400 años después en 19 962
finalmente Trinidad Tobago consiguió su
independencia del imperio británico y
como seguro que muchos ya estaréis
pensando No tardaron en aparecer nuevos
problemas para este recién nacido país
nada más conseguir su independencia por
ejemplo la economía de Trinidad y Tobago
comenzó a desplomarse por la reducción
la demanda internacional de sus
principales productos de exportación
Como por ejemplo el cacao el azúcar o
los cítricos la tasa de desempleos
amigosos alcanzó pronto el 15% para
finales de los años 60 y entonces las
protestas más en las calles Se volvieron
algo habitual sin embargo entre 1973 y
1981 debido al embargo del petróleo
saudí a occidente esta pequeña nación
caribeña se benefició por el aumento del
precio del barril de crudo el resultado
un enorme Boom petrolero que permitió
mejorar las condiciones de vida de los
ciudadanos de este pequeño país sin
embargo cuando las cosas con los árabes
volvieron a su cauce y terminó ese Boom
a principios de los 80 el nivel de gasto
público que había asumido el país de
pronto se convirtió en una losa INS
sostenible y con la diferencia entre las
importaciones y las exportaciones pasó
tres cuartas partes de lo mismo y es que
el problema es que en lugar de ahorrar
algo Trinidad y Tobago se gastaba todo
el dinero que llegaba con los
hidrocarburos de esta forma cuando los
precios del crudo y del gas cayeron la
economía del país entró en recesión y
para 1989 la sociedad se encontraba en
una situación desesperada un desempleo
de en torno al 22 por casi la mitad de
los jóvenes en paro y para colmo el
gobierno tuvo que reducir los subsidios
que había creado durante la época de las
vacas gordas Entonces como os podéis
imaginar las protestas masivas estaban
servidas y el malestar social fue más
evidente que
nunca el país amigos se encontraba casi
al límite y al final en 1990 pasó pues
lo que suele pasar en estas situaciones
en los países jóvenes con instituciones
débiles sí se produjo un golpe de estado
pero ojo porque no fue otro golpe de
estado típico llevado a cabo por
militares ni nada por el estilo aquel
golpe de estado lo dio Ni más ni menos
que un grupo radical islamista el
conocido como hamat al muslim Sí sí tal
cual como lo escucháis un golpe de
estado islamista en plena Sudamérica
amigos este grupo fundado en 1982 por
este hombre que veis en pantalla yasin
abu bakar un antiguo agente de policía
converso al islam intentó dar un golpe
de estado en julio de 1990 abu bakar ya
había tenido algunos problemas con el
gobierno central cuando este intentó
ocupar unas tierras que habían sido
concedidas a una cofradia islámica y de
hecho en 1985 fue detenido por no acatar
una sentencia judicial que le ordenaba
precisamente evacuar esas tierras y en
1988 el gobierno decidió ir un paso más
allá y llevar a cabo una serie de
redadas en ese mismo lugar arrestaron a
34 miembros de la organización por robo
violación y asesinato entre otros
delitos Abu bakar y sus fieles
consideraron que el gobierno les estaba
oprimiendo y desde luego no estaban por
la labor de aceptarlo Así que
aprovechando el tremendo malestar social
provocado por la crisis el 27 de julio
de 1990 112 Rebeldes islamistas tomaron
tanto al parlamento como las oficinas de
televisión de Trinidad hit bago amigo el
país se sumió entonces en el caos y
pronto empezaron los saqueos el
resultado es que 6 días y 24 muertos
después los Rebeldes desistieron Y sí se
entregaron Pero eso sí con la promesa
del gobierno de concederles una amnistía
amigos esta rebelión es Ni más ni menos
hasta el día de hoy la única insurgencia
religiosa islámica que se ha producido
en occidente ojo con esto pero sea como
sea la cuestión es que desde entonces
los sucesivos gobiernos de Trinidad y
Tobago han ido adoptando reformas
austeras sin preocuparse demasiado del
la mismo radical sin embargo estos
últimos años han dejado Claro que eso
fue un tremendo error
atentos tierra fértil para el
[Música]
extremismo hay algunos países que son
conocidos por exportar mucho petróleo
otros por ser potencias financieras y
algunos por ser núcleos turísticos sin
embargo en el caso de Trinidad y Tobago
su reputación ha venido forjándose por
noticias como esta detienen a tres
acusados de planear un ataque contra el
aeropuerto jfk de Nueva York detienen a
cuatro personas en Trinidad y Tobago por
la amenaza terrorista en carnavales
Trinidad y Tobago es el país con mayor
índice de jihadistas per cápita de hecho
siendo un país de 1,3 millones de
habitantes se calcula que hasta 240 de
sus ciudadanos se unieron al daes en
Oriente medio es una cifra que casi
igual a la de Estados Unidos pero
Estados Unidos multiplica su población
por 360 por lo que la pregunta es De
dónde salen tantos yihadistas en una
nación tan pero que Tan pequeña pues
amigos aquí las circunstancias
económicas juegan un papel fundamental
la mayoría de los que se han Unido al
daes en Trinidad y Tobago cumplen con
tres características muy específicas son
hombres afrodescendientes de unos 35
años que han sufrido discriminación que
provienen de un contexto de pobreza y
que a menudo han estado en la cárcel en
cualquier caso el reclutamiento de
jihadistas y su expansión ha sido
especialmente fácil debido a la
existencia de una red nacional muy bien
asentada Es decir que existe una red de
reclutamiento que está extendida por
toda la isla de Trinidad en el centro de
esta red se encuentra el imán nasim
Mohamed un hombre hombre que ha negado
constantemente su relación con el daes
pero que sin embargo tiene todos los
datos en su
contra por ejemplo el 70 por de los
jihadistas reclutados vivían cerca o
dentro de la comunidad religiosa que
Mohamed preside y no solo eso Sino que
unos 15 miembros de su familia también
se unieron al daes en Siria e Irak
incluidas su propia hija y sus nietos
además Mohamed está relacionado
familiarmente con emran Ali un hombre
que fue sancionado en 2018 por Estados
Unidos por financiar al Isis Así que
como podéis ver ti Tobago parece haberse
convertido en una inesperada cantera
para el yihadismo Internacional Pero por
qué este país y no cualquier otro pues
veréis el idioma de los trinitense es el
inglés un activo que le servía al daes
para aumentar su difusión además en
Trinidad y Tobago No hay ninguna ley que
prohíba unirse al califato y hasta el
brexit los trinitense podían entrar
libremente al Reino Unido y una vez en
Reino Unido podían moverse al resto de
Europa Así que este pequeño país era una
puerta de entrada perfecta a Europa para
la jihad global con todo no es de
extrañar que Estados Unidos haya
empezado a interesar en esta pequeña
nación caribeña de hecho en 2017 Donald
Trump ya se reunió con el entonces
Primer Ministro del país ki rowy en esa
reunión se comprometieron a luchar de
manera reforzada contra el terrorismo en
las Islas y crearon un nuevo sistema de
vigilancia no obstante los analistas
siguen bajo alerta el caso de Trinidad y
Tobago puede ser solo la punta de liberg
muchos vaticinan Un aumento del
yihadismo en toda América del Sur Pero
cómo de cierto es todo esto Pues bien
Vamos a
[Música]
verlo un nuevo problema en
Latinoamérica queridos amigos los que
nos veáis o proceda de América del Sur
seguramente cada vez que os hablan de
terrorismo en la región Pues penséis en
guerrillas como las fark en Colombia o
el sendero luminoso en Perú y no es
extraño Al fin y al cabo el terrorismo
jihadista en América Latina casi siempre
ha sido algo anecdótico de hecho nos
tenemos que remontar hasta los años 90
para encontrar los dos grandes atentados
jihadistas en esta región el de la
embajada de Israel en Buenos Aires en
199 y el que se produjo contra la
asociación mutual israelita Argentina la
amia en 1994 Y por cierto sabéis Quién
fue el responsable de estos dos ataques
Pues un viejo conocido de este canal el
grupo islamista hezbola amigos en 2006
el fallecido fiscal Alberto nisman y su
adjunto Marcelo Martínez Burgos
presentaron el informe de su
investigación sobre el atentado contra
la amia de 1994 en él se acusó
directamente al Estado de Irán de ser el
principal artífice de ese atentado y a
hezbolá de haberlo ejecutado ojo con
esto sin emb sin embargo sea como sea
esta no ha sido la única ocasión en la
que tanto Irán como su brazo terrorista
libanés hezbola han actuado en América
Latina los vínculos con Venezuela por
ejemplo también han sido destacados en
los últimos tiempos a través de una
retórica
antiamericano el favor de Venezuela para
poder explotar más fácilmente las
comunidades musulmanas de la región de
hecho el cártel de Los Soles que está
liderado por el diputado venezolano Dios
dado cabello y el cártel libanés creado
por walik mlet que tiene estrechos
vínculos con hezbola han colaborado en
repetidas ocasiones enviando armas y y
narcóticos a Damasco y Terán a través de
vuelos de la aerolínea venezolana con
viesa una práctica que se conoce como
aeroterrestres que este no es ni mucho
menos el principal punto para la entrada
del terrorismo jihadista a esta región
para eso tenemos que movernos más al sur
a una zona extremadamente caliente para
el crimen organizado estoy hablando de
la triple
frontera la triple frontera es el punto
en el que las fronteras de Argentina
Brasil y Paraguay confluyen un punto en
el que la corrupción de los funcionarios
de aduanas los escasos controles
fronterizos y el lavado de activos está
a la orden del día os hemos hablado de
ello en nuestros boletines de patreon en
este lugar organizaciones del crimen
organizado tanto procedentes de América
Latina como de otras partes del mundo se
dedican al narcotráfico la trata de
personas o el contrabando entre otros
muchos delitos Y quién creéis que
también opera allí pues efectivamente
hezbola Y no precisamente desde hace
poco lo lleva haciendo desde los años 80
por eso los tres países fronterizos y
Estados Unidos han llevado a cabo varias
iniciativas de seguridad en este punto
concreto tanto para acabar con la
presencia del crimen organizado como del
terrorismo jihadista sin embargo por
ahora estas estrategias no han servido
para mucho y la realidad es que el
crimen se ha intensificado en esta zona
Y sabéis qué país está siendo el más
perjudicado pues ni más ni menos que el
país más grande y poblado de toda
América Latina
Brasil Brasil lleva reportando la
presencia de terroristas jihadistas en
su territorio desde hace más de una
década en 2013 por ejemplo la Policía
Federal del país confirmó la presencia
de siete grupos yihadistas en el
territorio brasileño entre ellas hezbolá
hamás y alcaeda de hecho en 2016 Brasil
estuvo a punto de ser víctima de un
atentado alavista policía de Brasil
arresta a 10 personas sospechosas de
planear ataques terroristas para las
olimpiadas de Río de Janeiro y más
recientemente en 2023 las autoridades
brasileñas han avisado del comienzo de
una campaña de dentro del país por parte
de tablin hamat un movimiento islámico
Centenario que fue fundado en la India y
que ha estado en el punto de mira de la
inteligencia mundial es más se les ha
vinculado de hecho con alcaeda y con los
atentados de Madrid de 2004 así que ya
lo veis Por el momento no se han
producido nuevos atentados jihadistas en
Sudamérica desde aquellos que ocurrieron
en los años 90 en la Argentina pero la
tensión por la presencia jihadista en la
región va en aumento Trinidad y Tobago
es el mejor ejemplo de ello ahora muchos
analistas piensan de hecho que América
Latina podría llegar a convertirse en
uno de los nuevos ep centros para el
reclutamiento de jihadistas en todo el
mundo pero qué opináis vosotros creéis
que comenzaremos a ver atentados
jihadistas en América Latina tomará
Estados Unidos alguna medida para evitar
que el resto de subcontinente siga el
mismo camino que Trinidad y Tobago
queridos amigos podéis dejarnos como
siempre vuestras impresiones en los
comentarios y si este vídeo os ha
resultado interesante no olvidéis darle
al botón de like y suscribiros a visual
politic si es que aún no lo habéis hecho
una vez más Muchas gracias por estar ahí
un saludo y hasta la
próxima